hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
IHC protocol optimization and
troubleshooting tips presented by thomas
roll his scientific support specialist
at outcome i'm susie valdez of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
AB chem lab camp is an innovator in
reagents and tools ab cams purpose is to
serve life Sciences researchers globally
to achieve their mission faster
providing the research and clinical
communities with tools and scientific
support AB camp offers highly validated
biological binders and assays to address
important targets in critical biological
pathways before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
at Q&A button located on the lower left
of your presentation window and type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice that
you're viewing this in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right or use
that Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem I'd now like to
introduce our speaker
Thomas rule welcome Tom
okay I think we're ready to go
hi everybody this is Tom and welcome to
the webinar this presentation is a
really simple kind of introductory talk
about IHC protocol optimization if
you've been doing IHC all along you may
not have anything new to learn from this
but if you you are new
hopefully this will help you out and if
you have any questions of course you can
email them to us down the road and
you'll have some contact information at
the end of the talk for that ok we use
this ok sorry about that moving along so
the agendas can be basically how to
choose an antibody and IHC optimization
and we'll start off with how to choose
an antibody and this is assuming you
don't have one already you're searching
around looking for an antibody to use in
your work and what a lot of people do
when they're starting out they'll just
go straight to the Google and they'll
type in some search terms and once I
typed in here as an example our CD 31
antibody CD 31 being the cell surface
protein and then IHC to qualify the
search so that you're looking for an
antibody that's useful for CD 31 I HC
and you'll get a list of antibodies
basically these first few hits and the
results are ads paid for by various
antibiotic companies as you scroll down
you'll see other vendors and one thing
you can do it's kind of useful when
you're doing this kind of really broad
search is just to click on Google Images
and that will bring up lots of images of
different antibodies standing for CD 31
and if you click on each individual
image that will bring you typically to
the vendor page some of these might be
coming from publications but a better
way a more focused way to go about
looking for an antibody would be
to go to specific specific search sites
that specialize in antibodies or bio bio
reagents in general and a few examples
that I listed here they are going to be
collecting antibodies from multiple
sources academic as well as commercial
and you can filter the search results by
tested applications species reactivity
host species and other criteria so it's
a little more useful than just simply
doing a Google search or any kind of a
broad search engine the examples are
site ab lin Scott's directory bio
compare antibody pedia there's a bunch
of them but a lot of these sources will
ask and some ask you must ask to be
actually be listed up with these sources
sometimes you have to pay to be included
in these databases if you're a um if
you're a vendor selling antibodies so
that won't necessarily get every
antibody out there just the caveat
something to be aware of if you do use
those resources so if we anymore focused
if you just go straight to a supplies
website and I've chosen app conveniently
in this case and I started to do an
example search here for protein called
p38 which is a kinase and this search
just typing in p38 on the website search
box brings up 21 results and those can
be filtered by applying different kinds
of filters these are listed on the left
hand side in this example and you can
filter by species reactivity or
application and after applying some of
those filters to this list that came
down with - I filtered on antibodies
that have been knockout validated and
since I've done this actually this has
returned two results since I did this
few months ago we've actually added many
more antibodies that have been validated
against knockout samples and comparing
them to wild-type and this something
I'll discuss in a moment this kind of
validation but I'll have these two
antibodies sort of as a result of the
search and the top one is a rabbit
monoclonal antibody I believe and the
bottom one is a mouse monoclonal and
we're just going to pick that one at the
top there because it has a nice image of
immunohistochemistry and this
conveniently has a caption which
describes the the protocol that was used
to produce this image and so this is
normal human esophagus formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded and you see that's
standing pattern which is consistent
with what's expected for p38 nuclear
stain with some light cytoplasmic
staining this is a protein that will
shuttle back and forth between the
nucleus and the cytoplasm so this is
basically what's expected and this
caption is useful because it tells you
exactly what was what was done to
achieve this particular stain just a
15-minute incubation you'll see - which
is which is kind of short that's of
these kinds of protocol steps can be
modified to a certain extent depending
on what's convenience the incubation
time in particular and also the
detection that this was detected with a
secondary antibody conjugated to
horseradish peroxidase so gives and then
the substrate to do this brown stain and
the blue is a counter stain with
hematoxylin just to give you some
orientation as to where things that
issue are part of the validation of this
particular antibody was against the
knock out samples so these there's a
Western watch showing you four lanes in
addition to the molecular weight markers
on the far left in the first Lane is a
wild-type sample and the stain for p38
is shown up in the green here and then
the next Lane over is a same cell line
but with the
p38 knocked out and you see there's no
green there in the blot so this is
basically just telling us that the
antibody is in fact detecting p38 and
the last two lands are just HeLa cells
in tariqat cell lysates
showing then this basically also showing
us the specificity of the antibody
there's no cross reaction with other
proteins which would be apparent above
and below the red is a stain or I
believe gap th would be a load and
control just to demonstrate that there
was even loading at protein across all
four lanes and so now we've covered how
to choose an antibody I'm gonna move on
to a HC optimization and this is a
pretty busy little slide here I'm
showing you basic protocol that one
would use to sustain a tissue section
and specifically a paraffin-embedded a
section of paramedic tissue or frozen
tissue you're starting off with the
fixation step first of all for the
sample and then you're moving on to
embedding and sectioning and that goes
first to so its first two steps are
critical the choice a fixative it's
critical in so far as some antibodies
are not going to be able to stay in any
tissue that was fixed with a
formaldehyde based fixative and and and
some aren't compatible with that kind of
fixation at all so you would have to
either use frozen tissue or just move on
to a different antibody if you're locked
into using our sustaining
paraffin-embedded formalin-fixed tissue
and then the sectioning itself that
there's some variation there you can cut
a thin section which is the most common
kind of sample to be stained five to ten
microns thick if you're working in a
neuroscience lab you might be sectioning
much thicker things like 50 microns or
so and using a free-floating technique
and I'll discuss that a little farther
on I think and then the next step after
that after you've sectioned your slides
over section to tissue that is and
placed it on a slide the antigen
retrieval step serves to reverse some of
the effects of formaldehyde based
fixation and for most antibodies this is
necessary or at least it's not necessary
it will improve the intensity of the
stain if you simply apply this antigen
retrieval step and that can be a heat
induced retrieval which entails actually
boiling the section on the slide or an
enzymatic retrieval with them enzymes
like proteinase k of pepsin of trypsin
and then to point out that a lot of
people wonder if they can actually apply
heat mediated retrieval step to a
section of frozen tissue if the answer
is yes frozen tissue tends to be a
little more fragile than a section
that's been fixed with formalin and
embedded in paraffin so the remedy would
be to use a slightly lower temperature
maybe ninety degrees centigrade or 80
degrees centigrade for a longer amount
of time instead of just boiling the
section for 10 to 15 minutes which is
the standard protocol for a for a
paraffin-embedded section that's pretty
harsh like so then with a frozen tissue
section especially if you're working
with skin or certain other kinds of
tissue boiling is just going to knock it
right off the slide and you'll ruin the
morphology at the very least so lower
temperature longer incubation time can
remedy that
and the next step better before here
would be blocking with the nonspecific
binding of the antibody so you want to
use a percentage solution of serum from
the secondary antibody host species and
then once you've blocked all this
possibility ideally of the primary
antibody sticking non-specifically to
proteins in general you move on to the
step 5 which is actually incubation with
my antibody and then the optimal
concentration and incubation that's
typically going to be obtained from the
data sheets of the antibody in the cases
where the antibody has never been tested
for immunohistochemistry before you will
need to do some experiments to determine
what the optimal solution of the
antibody is a cube age can range from 15
minutes like I saw it we saw earlier
with that p38 antibody or you can go up
to just incubate overnight at 4 degrees
in the refrigerator the main the main
point to remember is never to let the
section dry out once it drives out
you're going to end up with lots and
lots of nonspecific binding of the
antibody see just know no specific
standing that's the no specific standing
that's can be distinguished from the all
this background staining so keep
everything wet all the time don't
anything dry out if you're committing it
overnight and wait a way to prevent
things from drying out if you're
incubating overnight is to keep them in
a chamber with say a wet paper towel
just a humidity humidified chamber and
then place it in the refrigerator then
the next step would be after the washing
off excess primary to body incubation
with the secondary antibody and then
finally rinsing off the excess of that
and incubating the substrate if you're
using a an enzyme for the detection or
no substrate appear simply using a
fluorescence detection method
fluorescently conjugated secondary ok so
we're going on that the very very
standard protocol and then poor results
generally have three kinds you'll see no
staining at all or you might see lots of
staining but it's all it's this kind of
general background nonspecific staining
with or without specific staining so you
might see some standing it looks correct
but it's kind of overwhelmed by all this
kind of background nonspecific standing
third kind of problem would be seeing
some staining that looks correct or
specific but it's incorrect I should say
not
correct but it looks like there's
certain things within the tissue that
are staining specifically and intensely
but it's incorrect staining it's same
say staining for protein where you
should exclusively see the nucleus you
might see lots of staining of the
cytoplasm but no nuclear staining or
less protein that's supposed to be
mitochondrial you might see just nuclear
staining so there'd be an example of an
incorrect staining or incorrect cell
types you might see staining at the cell
type that is not expected to express the
protein at all and the causes of these
poor results can be broadly classified
as either sample issues protocol issues
or reagent issues and let's start with
no staining due to sample issues and one
of the main causes would just simply be
that there's no protein to detect the
protein expression is low or absent and
so you want to be sure you're looking
your expectations are valid so you want
to review the literature and this is an
example let's see this is a protein
especially Mouse that in mouse tissue
specifically that is found in
macrophages but it's absent from some
macrophages which are localized within
t-cell areas of lymph nodes and spleen
so a very specific expression of this
particular protein so you should be sure
like I said to look for it we would
expect to see it which isn't to say that
you might discover something completely
new but you would have to do a lots more
experimentation to to confirm that and
that same protein in human is expressed
the expression is restricted to idiocy
no fills so this what I'm looking at
here this this database record on the
right hand side it's from unipro it's a
very useful useful tool for looking at
we're proteins that are expressed it has
lots of literature references to go
along with the sections in this database
record that refer to tissue-specific
expression and another resource we like
to go to is called the human protein
Atlas so if you're looking for in
particular a positive control some kind
of tissue where people have reported
detection of this protein through a
variety of different assays Western
blotting Eliza or what have you and in
history chemistry this human protein
Atlas will have lots of suggestions they
it presents tissue RNA expression data
and also tissue microarray IHC data but
they're this your petition microwave
data for many proteins is from just one
or two antibodies so their ambition is
to collect lots of data from lots of
different antibodies against any one
given protein and so definitely look at
protein Atlas org and you'll see lots of
examples of these images from the tissue
microarrays
by tissue microwave we mean a slide that
contains multiple tissue types all
stained with the one antibody and
they're a convenient way of looking at
where something is found in various
tissues and moving on to no staining due
to sample s you pour sample preparation
can be a factor so over under fixation
of the tissue or insufficient removal of
paraffin could lead to a negative stain
and it can be difficult to diagnose poor
sample preparation but of multiple
antibodies against several different
targets fell it needs to be considered
tissue samples prefix ation should be no
more than several millimeters in
thickness I think I wrote diameter here
but I we mean its thickness so that the
fixation
can be can permeate the entire tissue
formaldehyde based immersion fixation
for instance with para formaldehyde or
formalin that's a less for at least a
minimum of 24 hours perfusion fixation
which is another method of fixing the
tissue that's going to typically be
shorter and followed by post fixation
post immersion fixation over fixed
samples can be salvaged more easily than
under fixed samples by South's I mean
the over fixation can be reversed with
antigen retrieval that boiling that I
mentioned earlier to Antony retrieval
that will done that will reverse over
fixation under fixations a little more
difficult so you have to remember that
the fixative is moving from the outside
of the tissue to the interior if it's
under fixed to the interior have no
fixation and then subsequent steps in
the procedure might denature those
proteins in the interior and you'll see
just differences in staining intensity
across the across the tissue no staining
due to reagent or a protocol issue so
these are a little obvious but we'll go
over them anyway the antibody
concentration is too low you want to
stain series of dilution use a series of
delusions including the dilution
recommended obviously on the datasheet
that recommendation on the datasheet
might hold for the set the way that was
the antibody was validated but your
tissue is going to be different it might
be fixed for a longer amount of time
might have less of the protein so you
might see even if you get a negative
result that's just simply using more
antibody will produce the positive stain
or at least will intensify a relatively
weak stain with the secondary antibody
you want to check the datasheet for
isotype specificity and species
reactivity so for instance an anti
rabbit immunoglobulin secondary antibody
may not be able to sustain a
Emmaus primary antibody so you want to
match up the two species of reactivity
of the secondary with the species of the
primary antibody and and also the Isis
type some some anti Mouse immunoglobulin
secondary antibodies are is't ice ice
type specific so Isis actually be igg1
ID G to A to B IgG three and so on and
one way to check would be just to check
against another primary antibody the
secondary antibody does check that
against another primary antibody to
ensure quality that fails with another
primary antibody or multiple primary
antibodies there's a question of the
quality of that secondary antibody no
staining do two really gentle protocol
issues moving on to antigen retrieval I
mentioned this heat needed retrieval at
various you can use various PHS citrate
buffer at pH 6 it's really popular and
another one would be more Outland Tris
EDTA
at pH 9 and then another variety
altogether of integer retrieval with the
enzymatic retrieval with trypsin protein
s K or pepsin and I'm showing here some
data from a paper that compared
different PHS of answer to retrieval
buffer and they were examining two
different antibodies one was against the
progesterone receptor on the left and
another was looking at the antibody
against ecat here and on the right and
you see the results at the lower pH as
the e-cat here an antibody failed
altogether pH 3 progesterone receptor
antibodies stained intensely and then
also at pH 9 relatively weaker at the pH
is in between so just to show the each
antibody has its own requirements for
the D and the pH of the antigen
retrieval buffer and this paper actually
was much bigger it showed a big table
with lots of different antibodies they
tested under lots of different
conditions
and they graded the intensity of the
standing with these plus marks from from
none at all two plus three three plus
marks and just again demonstrating that
the ante to retrieval itself needs to be
optimized for each antibody again the
data sheet from the vendor should have
that all squared away for you so it
shouldn't be necessary for you to do it
yourself but a histology lab receiving
an antibody they haven't worked before
more often than not they'll test three
to two or three different PHS and
potentially enzymatic retrieval which is
simply digesting the tissue section well
as enzymes I mentioned off target of
background standing due to sample issues
so if you're looking to detect use of
fluorescent detection say directly
conjugated antibody the primary antibody
directly conjugated to a floor floor or
using a secondary antibody conjugated to
the floor for the issue of water
Florence's autofluorescence comes up a
lot especially in the green channel and
you'll see lots of red blood red blood
cells especially there fluorescing very
bright green typically you can ignore
the red blood cells since they're easy
to recognize as such another issue would
be with enzymatic detection endogenous
peroxidase or phosphatase with the
Polacks you can quench that with the
peroxidase with can quench that with
peroxide or the phosphatase with the
Bassem all but yea the remedy for the
auto fluorescence which I didn't mention
was to simply use the floor for with a
different wavelength sometimes just
moving from green to red will let me do
that okay off target background staining
do two sample tissue if using an avidin
biotin complex for detection the ABC
will detect endogenous biotin in the
tissue and this can be diagnosed with
the negative controlled tissue slide
which does not receive any primary
and anarion de body just the ABC reagent
so this avidin biotin complex which is
horseradish peroxidase or phosphatase
attached to it this is a detection
method people use to amplify a signal if
there's endogenous biotin in the tissue
that's ABC complex will stick to that
directly to that and create all kinds of
backgrounds standing basically wherever
the biotin is and so there's a way to
address that and it entails the simply
incubating the tissue section with some
avidin and then that avidin intern will
stick to the block and doujins biotin
and then if you follow that with some
biotin since the avidin has multiple
binding sites for biotin you want to
occupy all of those so it's just simply
adding its extra blocking step of avidin
then followed by biotin in addition to
the standard serum block and that should
take care of any kind of background
staining due to endogenous biotin
targets or background staining do two
reagents so we're getting close to the
end now the blocking reagents you want
to check for contamination of the serum
stock and you might want to try a
different reagent rack for example 5%
bovine serum albumin if the blocking
appears to be ineffective the primary
antibody again
you seem very weak standing or very
strong staining it consists serial
dilutions of that primary antibody to
find the dilution that's just right and
you can crease crease the number of wash
steps if you simply after the primary
antibody just wash once very quickly
that might be insufficient and there
might still be some primary antibody
soaked into the tissue section that
needs to be removed and then finally you
can include some detergent in the
antibody daily wince and wash buffer for
example 0.1%
triton 1x 100 between 20 and that will
help reduce the amount of nonspecific
staining you might get
primary and secondary antibody controls
these are pretty important eyesight
control in place of the primary antibody
Raziel reveals presence of unblocks FC
receptors on various white blood cells
for example B cells and macrophages and
a secondary only control no primary
antibody will reveal detection of
endogenous immunoglobulin in addition to
FC receptors so the tissue itself might
have some endogenous IgG that the
secondary antibody sticks to and
including this control with just no
primary antibody at all well I kind of
reveal should reveal if that's the issue
that's the problem or not the secondary
antibody there's lots and lots of
background staining then you have some
issue with that in the remedy would be
simply to choose a different secondary
antibody a lot of this would I've gone
over I've gone over pretty quickly
there's some nice videos on the AB cam
website and this one these two I picked
out sectioning a paraffin-embedded
tissue video protocol so this will
actually show you the sectioning itself
you might have a histology lab that's
doing all this for you but it can be
instructive to actually see exactly what
they're doing and then also we have the
video for I see a pair of and embedded
sections so this will go over you'll see
somebody actually going through those
steps we discussed earlier and you
really run into a lot of trouble of
course you can always contact us and
these are the contact details for AB cam
and that wraps it up I'll bring it back
to this contact page so you can look at
that and copy things down if you like
but if you have any questions you can
always contact us by email or by phone
ok
thank you so much Tom for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of this webinar if you have any
questions you'd like to answer please
ask now just click on that gooniac Q&A
button at the lower left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our audience
questions that are coming in our first
question tom is why would one want to
prepare thick sections for example 50
microns or more rather than thin
sections I basically got more
information so if you want to cut a thin
section that's typically what people are
just looking at two dimensions they want
to see something where things are next
to each other the thicker the section if
you have a confocal microscope and
you're using a immunofluorescent
detection because it's kind of move up
and down through that Z plane that
thickness of the section to the to see
things that what might be difficult to
find otherwise and so a lot of times
people working in New York neuroscience
are going to be working with the thick
sections of the brain or the spinal cord
because those cells have lots of
processes and dendrites and it's easier
to see cell contact computing you had a
fixed section this gives you a better
opportunity you can scroll up and down
through the Z a Z stack with a confocal
microscope to see the things that might
not be obvious so it might be hard to
find if you're working with this thin
section so that briefly would be why we
want to work with the thick section and
people working with brain also he's
point out that people working with these
thick sections are using a free-floating
staining technique and that's where
you're actually rather than placed in
the tissue section on the slide you're
just letting it float around in a bath
of antibody solution because it's so
thick you want to ensure that the
antibody is diffusing into that thick
section and one other wrinkle for that
kind of protocol the free-floating
immunohistochemistry is that you need to
permeable eyes with some kind of
detergent because that section is so
thick it's going to contain some intact
cells and in order for the antibody to
get inside of those cells if necessary
you need to permeable eyes this plasma
membrane with the detergent so that's
another variation thick versus thin
free-floating versus staining directly
on the slide but that it really briefly
was being why why people want to stay in
a thick section and and how
thank you so much Tom our second
question from our audiences which is
more sensitive florescent detection or
column colorimetric
detection it's difficult to say it
depends there's different varieties of
colorimetric detection so by
colorimetric we mean typically using an
enzyme and followed by a substrate of an
enzyme which lays down onto the tissue
section this insoluble precipitate and
that could be very very sensitive
there are ways to amplify that signal I
mentioned to avidin biotin complex
earlier and you can also use something
called tear amide signal amplification
which is even more it gives even more
sensitivity so when you're using those
kinds of extra tertiary steps you know
third steps get extremely sensitive
fluorescent detection as well as
sensitive people are using that mainly
just because it gives you its greater
contrast if you're using trying to stain
more than one protein you have the
option of standing at the green channel
versus the red channel and then maybe a
counter stain for the nuclei in the blue
channel so the fluorescence detection
can also be very fluorescent it can also
be very sensitive but it comes down to
choosing the a good primary antibody
more and then not so talks a long story
short it's hard to say which is more
sensitive but I think in general people
would say colorimetric detection with
the proper with the proper tertiary
technique would be more sensitive
which Tom and I want to thank our
audience for their participation today
our last question is what are the
advantages of frozen versus
paraffin-embedded tissue
IHC third question what are the
advantages of frozen versus
paraffin-embedded tissue I see the
advantage of frozen one of the big
advantage of the frozen is that it's
frozen tissue is that it's minimally
processed so you can imagine the tissue
section that's going through paraffin
processing that's removing all the water
in order to remove all the water replace
it with molten paraffin you're placing
the tissue in solvent that's compatible
with molten paraffin so it starts off
with ethanol varying degrees of
percentages of ethanol and then that's
followed by xylene and then eventually
you have this molten paraffin at 60
degrees centigrade so that's a lot of
that's a lot of treatment of the tissue
and a lot of cases that kind of these
solvents in this high-temperature
paraffin can destroy the epitopes that
an antibody wants to detect and simply
snap freezing a tissue instead it's a
much less harsh on the tissue the worst
that could happen might be it's kind of
if you're trying to store them long term
kind of a freeze thaw cycle might
eventually destroy the epitope of the
protein so briefly frozen is less harsh
and another big advantage of frozen
versus paraffin-embedded tissue would be
that the speed it's much faster in fact
a lot of during surgery there's a type
of surgery micro surgery called Mo's mo
HS which is developed by Frederick Mo's
in the 1930s and this is actually what
somebody's having a skin tumor treated
or removed the surgeon needs to know
exactly how much turn tumor has been
removed
and and and to the point and not not
removing too much normal tissue so I'll
actually take this tumor off the skin
and then freeze it and do an i HC while
this patient is still on the table and
come back with the results and they
might have to do that again
so you can get actually all this
information within an hour doing this
frozen frozen immunohistochemistry
whereas paraffin processing takes more
often than not brought the whole process
it just goes overnight you know it's
going to take at least five to six hours
to get the tissue from fresh to embedded
in paraffin so that's very quick
advantage of paraffin embedded IHC it's
typically the morphologies preserved
that are there's more detail in a tissue
section that's formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded compared to a frozen
tissue so those that yeah that's the
that's in a nutshell thank you so much
thomas i'd like to thank you again for a
wonderful presentation i'd also like to
thank lab roots and abbe cam for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go i want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon buh-bye